>> RIPPED FROM TODAY'S INTERNET
HEADLINES IT IS RAPID REFRESH.
>> GOOD NEWS FOR GUILTY
PLEASURES, NETFLIX IS TESTING A
PRIVATE VIEWING FEATURE THAT
WOULD HIDE ALL OF YOUR
EMBARRASSING SELECTIONS FROM
YOUR VIEWING HISTORY. SO YOUR
ROOMMATE NEVER HAS TO KNOW ABOUT
ALL YOUR LOST WEEKENDS WITH ALL
EIGHT SEASONS OF SAY YES TO THE
DRESS OR THE FACT THAT BREAKING
AMISH IS IN YOUR SPANK BANK.
>> COMEDIANS WHAT SHAMEFUL
NETFLIX SECRET DO YOU WISH YOU
COULD HIDE FROM THE WORLD? MIKE
PHIRMAN?
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN HOUSE OF
CARDS BUT I LOVE IT.
>> POINTS TO MIKE PHIRMAN.
>> MOVING ON.
IF YOU WITH WONDERING WHY THERE
WAS A PALPABLE SEXUAL ENERGY
RADIATING FROM YOUR LOCAL ARTS
AND CRAFTS STORE THIS WEEKEND,
IT'S BECAUSE THE TRAILER FOR THE
TRAILER OF THE UPCOMING 50
SHADES OF GREY MOVIE HIT THE
INTERNET VIA BEYONCE'S INSTAGRAM
AND IT HAS ALMOST 400,000 LIKES.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW IT TO YOU,
BUT FOR YOUR SAFETY, MAKE SURE
YOUR MOM'S BOOK CLUB IS OUT OF
THE ROOM LEST THEY FLY INTO A
CHIMPANZEE LIKE SEXUAL FRENZY
AND HAVE TO GO SWIFT ONE OUT IN
THE MINIVAN.
>> [ MOANING]
>> IS THIS MOVIE ABOUT POOPING?
BECAUSE IT SOUNDED LIKE POOPING.
>> IS THAT WHAT THAT MEANS?
>> OBVIOUSLY THERE'S NOT LOT OF
CONTENT HERE, SO COMEDIANS, SAY
SOMETHING TO GET 50 SHADES OF
GREY FANS TO GET ALL HOT AND
MOIST IN THEIR HIGH WASTED
COSTCO JEANS. STORM --
>> 50 SHADES -- IT'S GONNA BE
MORE HEAVING BREATHING --
THAN YOUR HUSBAND'S SLEEP APNEA.
>> POINTS, POINTS.
>> MIKE PHIRMAN.
>> YOU REMIND ME OF MY LATE
WIFE.
QUICK, LET'S DO IT BEFORE SHE
GETS HOME.
>> WELL DONE, POINTS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NEXT HEY, MILLENNIALS, GET OFF
BUZZ ALDRIN'S LAWN.
HERE'S A CLIP OF HIM PUNCHING A
GUY WHO SAID THE MOON LANDING
WAS FAKE. I JUST LOVE TO WATCH
IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> YOU ARE A COWARD AND A LIAR
AND A THIEF.
>> OH!
>> THAT, THAT DID NOT SEEM LIKE
THE ACTIONS OF A COWARD AT ALL.
>> I HEARD THAT CLIP WAS FAKE
THOUGH.
>> 100 POINTS TO MIKE PHIRMAN.
ON TWITTER THIS WEEKEND, BUZZ
LAID CLAIM TO THE FIRST SELFIE
IN 1966 AFTER HE LOCKED HIS KEYS
INSIDE THE GEMINI CAPSULE
HERE IS HE IS WAITING FOR AAA.
COMEDIANS HOW WOULD YOU BREAK
THE NEWS TO BUZZ ALDRIN THAT
HE'S GOING TO BE THE SECOND MAN
ON THE MOON? PAUL?
>> EENIE, MEANIE, MINIE, SORRY
BUZZ, IT'S SCIENCE.
>> POINTS.
MIKE.
>> NO, NEIL IS JUST OPENING, YOU
ARE THE HEADLINER.
>> OH, THAT IS SO GOOD, OH, GOOD
BAND JOKE.